المبادرة الصينية للسلام بتهذيب
شديد. وتقول ان الصين هي الاجدر
لغايته اولا التنين الصيني ومن
خلفه الدب الروسي المترقب امل
قوات الناتو الى حدوده. واليوم
تفاجأ بانهم قد اصبحوا هناك على
تهدف لمنح اوكرانيا المزيد من
الوقت لتعزيز قدراتها العسكرية.
المنتصرة. روسيا ظلت طوال فترة
العملية العسكرية تؤكد انها مع
الداعية لاستمرار الحرب. ظهر في
مشهد تمثيلي يعلن خطة عجيبة
الدائم للتوصل الى السلام عندما
اعلنت روسيا عن هدنة مؤقتة
لموسكو. سلام الغرب العجيب. كل
شيء كان يدل على ان الغرب يسعى
زاعمين ان روسيا ترفضه. ومستدلين
بذلك بزيارات عدد من رؤساء
الالماني الى الصين لم تكن من
اجل احلال السلام. ولا يوجد فيها
مدينة باخموت وما بعدها للتاريخ
يا رفاق. في ليلة واحدة تغيرت
كانت الزيارة الوحيدة لمسؤول
اوروبي ذهب فعلا للصين ليدعوها
اتهم البيت الابيض الصين التي
تقدمت بخطة السلام بانها وسيط
والمحايد باتهام واضح لما تقوم
به امريكا مع اوكرانيا. بينما
الاموال لعملائهم فلم يكن امام
الامريكان الا كما يقولها
على المبالغ المالية وكشف الية
التواصل الامن وطريقة تحويل
للتواصل الامن. وهنا ندخلعت اليا
باشا حيث استغل الطيارون الموقف
اجواء اوديسا حتى الوصول غرب
اوكرانيا والهبوط في القاعدة
ازدادت واشنطن ثقة لتبدأ التواصل
بالطيارين منذ شهور واستمرت
سيرهم بالطائرات وطريقة الفرار.
فابلغوهم بالطيران المنخفض في
الصواريخ النووية الروسية الاحدث
في العالم واقواها. نعم هو ما
لفترة من الزمن. عندها ابدى
الطيارون خشيتهم من كشف امرهم
الولايات المتحدة ليست الصين
لتستنسخ اسلحة اعدائها. اذا فما
عكسية. نعم عندما تحاول اقوى
دولة في العالم ونقصد امريكا
ولكن هنا سنأتيكم بالاجابة? فهيا
بنا يا رفاق. سرقة تأتي بنتيجة
الامر? اسئلة حلزونية شائكة
ومعقدة? تجول في عقولنا وعقولكم?
هل باع الروس طائراتهم
للامريكان? ثم هل يريد الغرب
عن قبول انضمام فنلندا الى حلف
الناتو. اليوم روسيا تعتذر عن
روسيا. وهو نفس الكلام الذي كرره
قبل ايام قليلة عندما تم الاعلان
الدول على الزينونيسكي بسبب
ظهوره الدائم وتصريحاته المستمرة
العسكرية الروسية من خرسون قبلها
بنحو شهر. عندما تزيد لوم بعض
للسلام. حتى لو هزمت روسيا فلن
تقبل بها فكيف تقبلها وهي
اعلنت امريكا واوكرانيا على
الفور ان تلك الدعوة للهدنة
وايقاف اطلاق النار من طرف واحد
في شهر يناير بداية هذا العام
مستندين الى شعور زائف بالزهو
والنصر نتيجة انسحاب القوات
بانها مجرد خدعة واصفين اياها
بالنفاق. وانها هروب من الهزيمة
صادقة للسلام لم تحظى زيارته
بتغطية اعلامية مناسبة وربما
بتقديم مبادرة سلام. لكن الغرب
يكذب باستمرار فمن ذا الذي سيصل
ميركل بان الناتو خدع روسيا التي
طلبت ضمانات امنية بعدم وصول
السلام الذي يحفظ امنها لا غير.
وهذا ما اكدته الالمانية السابقة
كما ظهر امين عام حلف شمال
الاطلسي بعدها ليؤكد نفس فكرة
تكون قد سمعتم بهذه الزيارة الان
لاول مرة. بالاضافة الى ما سبق
ميركل حين قالت ان الناتو خدع
روسيا وان اتفاقيات مسك كانت
فالرئيس الروسي بوتين كان قد
اعلن اكثر من مرة لاستعداد بلاده
انهم رفضوا المبادرة ربما قبل ان
يقرأوها حتى. لم يرفضوها فحسب بل
غير محايد حتى يقبل خطتها
للسلام. ولهذا جاء رد الخارجية
ما يدعو الى تشجيع السلام مطلقا.
لكنهم كانوا مرسلين من امريكا
في شهر مارس الفائت تعاطت روسيا
بايجابية كبيرة مع المبادرة لحين
تم رفضها من امريكا بلغة قاطعة
وبشكل سريع جعل البعض يقولون
الاسباني الذي ذهب دون موافقة
الاتحاد الاوروبي. ولان دعوته
الصينية. وللذي يشعل الوضع اكثر
ويحرض ويدعم طرفا بالسلاح
اللعب على الدب الروسي؟ ثانيا
عندما تقدمت الصين بخطة السلام
اوروبا الى الصين. وتلك كذبة
سمجة تدحضها الكثير من الحقائق
الى الصين لدعوتها الى ايقاف
تعاملاتها مع روسيا والعمل
للانتصار في الحرب الاوكرانية.
حتى اقتحمت قوات فاجنر الروسية
الجوية هناك. وهنا كانت المفاجأة
الصادمة ففي اليوم التالي اتصلت
المخابرات الروسية بالعناصر
الاستخباراتية الامريكية وشكروهم
يزالون مسعري حرب يفرضون
العقوبات على روسيا ويدعمون
المهمة. يا له من مبلغ مغر. فلما
لا ينفذ الطيارون رغبات
الامريكان. العملية وطلب
الطيارون من الامريكيين تحديد خط
فيا لا ايها الغربيون لكن على
مين يا ابن الناس هل تريدون
اشبه برسالة تحذير للصين. وليس
دعوة للعمل على احلال السلام.
المصريون. اعمل نفسك ميت اعمل
نفسك ميت. فكانت ضربة معلم
بحرص على العمل على مبادرتها
للسلام هي زيارة رئيس الوزراء
اوكرانيا بالمال والسلاح اصبحوا
يتحدثون عن السلام في اوكرانيا
الغرب بشكل كامل حول الاوضاع في
اوكرانيا وبعد ان كانوا وما
تسليمهم من مليون دولار لكل
طيار. وهناك المزيد عند اتمام
بسبب التواصل معهم عبر الانترنت
والهاتف فمنحهم الامريكان الية
ليطلبوا تحويل مبالغ ضخمة لهم.
لكنهم يخشون ادخال المبالغ في
اسعد الامريكان باعتباره سيمثل
انتصارا عسكريا ومعنويا يفقد
ما اعلنت المخابرات الروسية
احباطها عملية الامريكية لقاذفات
طمأنهم الامريكان واعطوهم الية
لوصول الاموال بصورة امنة وتم
حساباتهم فيتم كشفهم. واشنطن
تأتي لهم بالحل. نعم. هناك
بالطيارين المعتمدين للقاذفات
الروسية كتجربة يمكن ان تنجح
اصدقاء؟ حيث تفاجأ الامريكان
بردود ايجابية من طيارين روس ما
النووية. فهل يصل الامريكان
لهدفهم بهذه السهولة؟ ولم لا يا
الاعتبار للامريكان وسط الهزائم
الكبيرة التي منيت بها واشنطن
سمعتم ويا لها من سرقة كانت
ستستحوذ على لقب سرقة القرن يا
الروس الثقة بجيشهم ويمثل
انتصارا امريكيا يعيد بعض
بالعقوبات التي فرضت على روسيا
من امريكا واوروبا. وهذا الامر
لنوضحها لكم كما يلي. اول زيارات
الرئيس الفرنسي ومن قبله
بطائراتهم فتصل ملايين الدولارات
الى الكرملين. ما هذا الذي يجري?
السلام في اوكرانيا حقا? اذا
فاين هي المبادرة الصينية من
سادة. بدأ الامر بمحاولة من ضباط
المخابرات الامريكية للتواصل
ويمكن ان تفشل ووعدوهم بملايين
الدول مقابل الفرار مع القاذفات
عسكريا في اوكرانيا ويا لها من
ضربة ستصيب موسكو في مقتل.
الذي يحاول ابناء العم سام ان
يفعلوه لقد اربكوا اذاننا قليلا.
وامريكا ترفض. ايعقل هذا? ترد
واشنطن باغواء طيار لاستدراجهم
باخموت. وما بعد باخموت ليس كما
قبلها. روسيا تجنح للسلام
المتحدة والحلفاء الغربيون سنترك
الاجابة لكم
ورا. طالت الحرب او قصرت فما بيد
الغرب حيلة. لقد انفرط العقد
سرقة سلاح اخر فذلك هو الجنون
بعينه. نحن نعلم جيدا ان
عدادها عن العمل. في اوكرانيا
بدأت الحكاية حتى وصلت الى
والغرب يفاوض ليسترد ما يخسره
يوميا ويا لها من خسارة لا يتوقف